you just can't do a review of the matrix
without a pair of these whoa welcome
back to a long-dead segment that has
been on my channel for a while that I
have not resurrected and it's time to
resurrect it my favorite movies in which
I tell you guys some of my favorite
movies I have a playlist right now on
the home page for my channel for my
previous Ford videos in this segment if
you'd like to learn more about some of
my favorite movies they're not any type
of descending or ascending order there's
no list I do not have an all-time
favorite movie as so many people have
asked me I do however have favorites and
the matrix is certainly one of them
let's talk about it matrix came out in
1999 and I'll never forget the way that
it spread amongst pop culture and
particularly my friends she had looked
cool it was an intriguing looking movie
but no one really expected it to be as
incredibly mind-blowing as it was in
every way it wasn't just a really
awesome special effects driven film it
wasn't just a film that had really great
kung-fu fight sequences it was a movie
that had a really interesting
philosophical story with tons and tons
of meetings metaphors and honestly
something that seemed slightly tangible
in a very frightening way now I'm going
to talk a little bit about spoilers for
the matrix I'm not going to get too
heavy with spoilers but there's going to
be some things in here if you haven't
seen the film that you might not want to
know I just want to warn you guys but if
you have not seen the matrix definitely
see it it is worth your time without a
doubt if you are a fan of movies see the
trailers for this movie were so great
because they didn't give away the fact
that the matrix is this fake reality
that we're supposed to believe is real
and that we can be unplugged from that
and the real world is a place where
mankind has been devastated by our own
creation of artificial intelligence and
the matrix in the film is described as a
computer artificially based system and
just like any computer or any other
artificially based anything you can bend
the rules a little bit you can change
things which gives the filmmakers the
excuse to be able to have people jumping
and flying and flipping in slow motion
dodging bullets and everything and it
was like the most smart and tech-savvy
way to be able to make a kick-ass action
movie and do anything you want and have
it actually be plausible
if you've ever actually sat down and
read the Wachowski brothers script for
The Matrix it's incredible the amount of
detail they put in the description of
the action because if you ever do any
script reading you will find that a lot
of scripts do not take the time to
describe the action it will say two
characters fight two characters chase
each other or something very boring like
that if you actually open the script to
the most famous bullet time sequence in
the matrix where neo bends backwards and
the bullets fly over him
the way they described that in the
script was just like reading a novel it
was so awesome to be able to read a
script that was just as interesting as
watching a movie because they took so
much time that what Chomsky's did in
writing this script in so much care and
not just the awesome action sequences
but the characters in this movie one of
the reasons this first matrix film was
so much more well-received than it's two
sequels is because of the fact that it
understood that the action was just an
addition to character into story because
I rewatched this film two days ago in
preparation for this review and one of
the things that surprised me so much
about it was I forgot how suspenseful
the film actually is there's a lot of
really great tension that builds and
builds as this movie progresses to the
finale which is this giant action
extravaganza and some people were like
well it just went into the cliched
shootout and big and fight sequence and
then the chase sequence and blah blah
blah but the fact of the matter is a
movie can offer tons of cliched elements
and tons of tropes we've seen before but
if it presents it in a different and
intriguing way like The Matrix did it's
extremely successful this is by far in
my opinion Keanu Reeves Best Performance
and you know he's given performances in
the past we were like ooh no I love
Keanu Reeves though he's like people
have described him as the most likable
bad actor on the planet I like the guy
in real life too he seems like a really
cool guy but here he's just perfect for
this role of neo and he really commits
to the action scenes as well which is
something else to watch our skis did a
great job in in regards to their
directing duties because you see Hugo
Weaving and Laurence Fishburne and
carrie-anne moss and Keanu Reeves
kicking butt on screen and you know it's
them because the shot lingers on them
for a long time and it pans in on them
as they're doing these incredible fight
moves and the music by Don Davis was
also a great addition to this
the way he used the different sections
of the orchestra to reflect off one
another to create that really great
echoing sound the movie definitely has a
lot of Christ's metaphors that's for
sure I mean neo is the one by the way if
you rearranged neo you get one just
little little thought there he's the one
prophesied to come back and save
everyone and while that can sometimes be
heavy-handed in other films where it's
like just pounding me over the head with
its visual metaphors it doesn't feel
that way in this movie now I'll never
forget the way this movie affected my
friends and I back in the late 90s and
early 2000s we made so many short films
in which we tried to emulate The Matrix
and since you guys are awesome I'm going
to show you a little tiny clip from one
of our matrix short films is only a few
seconds long because that's as only as
much I'm going to show you but here you
go this is us trying to do a matrix
fight back in like I think it was the
year 2000 I'm not in this clip it's two
of my friends
yeah we really love the matrix that was
one of the coolest things about the
movie was that it was able to tell such
an interesting story but somehow still
appeal to kids who like to see people
jump around and punch each other I think
the matrix has one of the best first
acts ever in a movie culminating when he
wakes up in the liquid pool and he sees
all the bodies that first act that ended
with that was so incredibly powerful and
one of the most surprising first acts I
had ever seen in a movie even back in
the 90s and this is one of the things
I've been trying to emphasize lately is
that you got to stop ruining movies and
trailers because the matrix was an
experience in theatres people were
shocked it was like the ending of The
Sixth Sense except 45 minutes into it it
was so incredibly awesome The Matrix has
amazing action sequences that to this
day are not rivaled and are continuously
copied over and over again back in the
early 2000s the one with Jet Li a movie
called the one featuring bullet time it
was such a blatant copy off of The
Matrix so many movies copied off this
movie and not one even its sequels have
come to being as good as this film the
story is absolutely solid the script is
incredibly well-written the acting is
good the music is good the actions
incredible the matrix without a doubt
deserves an A+ I'm going to try to do
more of these videos in which I tell you
guys some of my favorite movies because
there are a lot of fun to let you guys
kind of know what really are the films
that inspired me a lot and ones that
really got my mind going a lot when I
was younger I also want to tell you guys
about something pretty cool this website
called Warby Parker com actually sent me
these sunglasses and said hey you're
doing a matrix review you want to wear
some of our sunglasses in them and I
said actually that'd be pretty freakin
awesome the coolest thing is they
actually sent me five pairs which is
amazing this is something this website
does they send you five home Tryon pairs
of sunglasses or regular glasses then
you can wear for free and see which ones
you want to pick they're very cheap
they're very stylish and when they
contacted me I said that is pretty
awesome I really really like what
they're doing one of the coolest things
these guys are doing
is the fact that when you purchase a
pair of these it helps a child in need
or an adult in need in another foreign
country who cannot afford to get glasses
or sunglasses for themselves that is one
of the coolest things that Warby Parker
does and that's one of the reasons I'm
very proud to be working in a promotion
with them for these glasses if you want
to go to Warby Parker comm slash Chris
Warby Parker comm slash Chris you can
order these five sunglasses to try on at
home for free and see which ones you
like and then let them know which ones
you like they're very cheap they're very
reasonable and the fact that they do
that charity work I just think is so
awesome guys thanks so much for watching
my review of the matrix and I will try
to do more of these I will I have a lot
of reviews to do this week I'm going to
have a review for edge of tomorrow
pretty soon in Maleficent as well thanks
as always for watching guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mini heist